are incredible press secretary this
White House Press Secretary my God is
this going to be amazing does she has
anyone been more qualified or better at
their job in the history of the world
than Korean John Pierre female lesbian
women of color data secretary's
unprecedented
here she is talking about this whole
Tech censorship collusion thing there
was a reporting in The Intercept about
opportunities for the federal government
to identify for social media companies
different posts that contains uh what
was perceived as misinformation about
the origins of covid the vaccine other
things as well you know such as Ukraine
or the US withdrawal from Afghanistan
yeah so um look I'll say this um the the
administration
um the bite Administration remains fully
uh committed to our mission to protect
the security and resilience of our um of
of our you know elections at Safeguard
election infrastructure that includes
combat combating disinformation that is
something that we are committed to
um you know we work to protect that uh
protect Americans from disinformation
that threatens the Homeland including
malicious efforts spread by Foreign
adverse
adversaries
adversaries sorry pardon me began before
the disinformation governance board was
established in fact some of that work
began before this Administration so I
you know I want I want to be very clear
that cross-agency work continues to this
day I don't want to don't want to get
ahead of of anything else this is a
Department of Homeland Security so I
would refer you to them so you are
flagging uh misinformation I don't have
anything more than ad this is a
Department of Homeland Security that I
refer to malice I feel like she's like a
sort of living walking breathing version
of why you're an anarchist that it's
like anyone that gets in any of these
positions of power they just become
useless parts of the machine I I don't
want to say I feel bad for her but it's
hard for me to think what I would do
differently if I was her if the if
there's the receipts right if that's
your gig yes and you know that you have
to get up there and spew lies the
Washington press Court they're not all
dumb I mean these people are smart they
sometimes ask for tough questions I
sometimes ask myself okay if I was in
her position uh what would I do
differently and she's really up against
it because thanks to social media as
opposed to you know before social media
you you could be whatever lie you want
you you got to just convince that one or
two journalists that what you're saying
or have to repeat your lie and it's fine
but now thanks to social media you
there's receipts 24 7. if I spew one lie
today it in five minutes it's gonna
someone's gonna have the counter or the
the Tweet of mine from ten years ago
where I said the contrary I don't know
what I would do differently in her
position she's really uh maybe I would
have resigned you know and like saki had
the sense to do
yeah viva do you feel any sympathy for
her I mean we everyone knows she's going
up there and lying about everything
that's sort of what the gig is in the
first place as a White House Press
Secretary but she has like an
extraordinary level of it because of the
Endless amount of lies and the fact that
some of this stuff's getting exposed in
real time now which as malice points out
that wouldn't have happened say 15 years
ago do I feel bad for her I feel bad for
everybody even people who don't know
that they should feel bad for themselves
what what really nauseates me about
jean-piev's particular situation is she
is being exploited racially genderized
sexual or she's being exploited it's the
ultimate Act of racism actually to take
someone and use them as a political tool
so that any critique of them on the
substance can be spun off as being
racist uh homophobic uh you know gender
whatever she is being abused through her
race gender identity uh sexual
orientation she's being used as a
political Pawn by Joe Biden a man with
the history of this that's what pisses
me off about this entire story